There's a fine line between being a hopeless romantic and just being hopeless.
These tips will help keep you on this side of cheesy.
You will need insight into your partner,...
...cliche avoidance, writing skills and an act of kindness.
Step one.
Know your partner's tastes, especially when it comes to public displays of affection.
What's hopelessly romantic to one person is mortifyingly cheesy to another.
Step two. Avoid cliches.
If your romantic gesture is a staple of bodice-ripping novels and bad romcoms,...
...it's probably more cheesy than romantic.
Step three.
Unless you're a professional singer-songwriter, don't write your love a song.
Insipid lyrics, out of tune singing, one-note guitar strumming?
They haven't got time for the cheese.
Step four. Do try your hand at writing your sweetie a love letter on real paper.
To make it romantic without being cheesy, keep it simple and straightforward.
Don't compare their lips to rubies or their eyes to diamonds.
Just tell them honestly why you love them.
If you write them a love poem, make sure it doesn't rhyme.
Step five. When it comes to gifts, treat your lover like a grown-up.
If the present is something a five-year-old would enjoy, it's cheesy, not romantic.
Step six. Do something nice for them that makes their day a little brighter...
...or their life a little easier.
Sometimes, just being kind is the most romantic gesture of all.
Did you know? Honolulu was voted the most romantic city in the United States...
...and Dallas-Fort Worth was voted the least romantic.